We will now give a slightly more complicated problem of the form we're going to be using
we're going to be using and I hope you won't be too confused.
So, this is it. There's two parts to it.
There's the print command as before but rather than printing 0.3 directly,
we're going to print the function that computes something from 0.3.
Right now it's identity is going to print out exactly the same value
but we're doing this is to set ourselves up to print something else.
And here is how f is defined.
We define f with the argument p that will be set to 0.3,
to be just a function that returns exactly the same value.
Why do we do this? Well, to practice programming.
So, hit the run button and see what happens.